If they have plants, I would get
a couple of cacti,
which is plural for cactus.
Sure, I knew that, yep.
I didn't know that,
somebody corrected me.
I was like back the (beep) up.
Who corrected you with cacti?
I hate that person.
A Dutch person, a Dutch person.
Oh, god.
Europeans love to correct me.
Your husband's Dutch, right?
He is.
Gross.
I know, but his (beep)
tastes good.
True, true.
He tasted Mile's (beep).
He knows what's up.
What are you gonna do? We got
drunk, shit got out of hand.
You never know what's
gonna happen with Mrs. Buteau.
That's true.
Just like these stale pretzels.
Absolutely.
Just salty and filling.
Yep.
What's up, everybody.
Welcome to Stupid Questions
with Chris Distefano.
I'm with Michelle Buteau,
actress, comedian.
Yes.
She's got a show called
Late Night Whenever.
It's a dope cool podcast.
She hosts it.
I'm making check, I'm
making checks.
What else you got?
I got titties.
I like Rose and humus.
Is that you just lifting
my titties?
They are that heavy.
They are, yes.
I haven't felt it,
but they look heavy.
They look nice.
Do you wan tot feel it?
Go ahead.
Uh, is that-
It's okay. It's okay.
Just feel it.
Are you telling me to do it?
Yes. Do it. Just feel it.
Oh, wow. That is nice weight.
They're heavy, yeah.
If you could shower
in any breakfast drink,
what would you shower in?
Oh my God.
What would you say?
Mimosas on my titties all day.
Wow, interesting.
Are you serious?
You want to bathe
in that brunch shit.
Oh, gets the party started.
Started. We got to go
to brunch together.
Here's a stupid question.
What's the strangest thing
you've ever bought or seen
at a convenient store?
Oh my God, a convenience store?
Yeah.
You know what? I'm so glad
you're asking me these
questions.
I saw this
one convenience store.
Where was it, like upstate New
York? Ok.
It was a tampon that is
specifically made for alcohol.
What do you mean?
What do you mean
specifically made for alcohol?
It was a alcoholic tampon.
Oh, that's how you're
getting drunk?
Yeah, without your breath
stinking.
It's just for women
or it's for men?
What do you mean?
Live your life, girl.
I don't know you.
Wow, Christopher.
I don't know flexible you is.
That is weird. I've never seen
anything quite that weird
at a convenience store.
Well, you weren't looking
for tampons.
If you could switch places
with another comedian,
who would it be?
Oh God.
The first person that pops
into my mind was Joan Rivers.
Yeah, that's a good one.
Because when she had her
late night talk show
and everyone shitted on her,
I'd love to go back in time
and be like, "(beep)."
Also, like I watch
Whoopi Goldberg on The View.
I don't know if she's high.
I don't know
if she's wearing a bra.
I don't care.
She is so smart.
I know that she has
a Japanese toilet.
Interesting.
I feel like if I had a Japanese
toilet cleaning my bum,
in all the right ways,
nooks and crannies and crevices,
I might be smarter too.
I guess I could be Joy Behar
I sound like her.
We have the same voice.
I would just put on a wig,
and then I'm Joy Behar.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's your drag alias.
That's a good ...
That's a stupid ...
Drag questions.
I don't think it's stupid.
I think it's beautiful.
I think it's beautiful too.
I'm just kidding.
I know.
I love a sorry broke white guy.
Did you have a good time here,
Stupid Questions?
Is that a stupid question?
It can be stupid, but I'm just
looking for an honest response.
No, I had fun. I had fun
You had fun?
No, I had so much fun.
It's nice hanging out with you
like not in the back of a
comedy club waiting to go on.
Yeah, we got your stupid gift,
two stupid gifts.
Most people just give one,
but you got two.
Are you talking about my tits?
Yes. First, this is
a bottle of Rose.
Oh my God.
Because we know
how much you love Rose.
I love Rose.
And then, you always say "hay",
so there you go.
It's cow hay.
This is so-
Hay.
Authentic. Hay.
Hay. That gift is for you.
Hay and Rose, and it rhymes.
See you later.
Bye.
Is this real Rose?